這裡是 AI 101，全網最幽默的 AI 新聞
OpenAI最新報告點名北京的月之暗面
指控這家人工智慧公司用「對抗式模型蒸餾」
大規模抽取OpenAI的模型能力
怎麼抽？
沒有人破解密碼
操作者先拿到一段加密推理
搬到新對話
要求同一體系的模型逐字解碼
等於沒撬保險箱，讓模型自己念出內容
而且量很大：短短2天
就湧進大約1萬6000次請求
這些是抽取嘗試，不代表都成功
OpenAI也只把核心群集
連到月之暗面相關人士
為什麼推理這麼值錢？
最後答案通常不含解題過程
推理過程才看得出模型怎麼拆解問題、修正錯誤
值錢的不只是答案，是得到答案的方法
拿到推理之後呢？
讓強大的「教師模型」當示範
訓練規模小、
成本低的「學生模型」去模仿
這就叫知識蒸餾
不過蒸餾本身不是駭客手法
早在2014年
研究人員就把它整理成正式方法
真正越線的是怎麼拿資料：
開一堆假帳號、透過代理服務
把別人的模型變成免費教師
說到偷學，同一個7月，白宮也開過火
7月22日
白宮指控月之暗面為了開發Kimi K3
蒸餾了Anthropic的Fable
財政部長也說正在考慮制裁
把7月攤開來看更巧
7月17日月之暗面發布Kimi K3
7月22日白宮指控，才隔2天
7月24到25日OpenAI就偵測到大批異常請求
7月28日前全面阻斷
可是時間軸也有破綻
Fable 5到7月1日才恢復全球開放
離K3發布只隔約16天
研究者質疑這夠不夠取樣、訓練、
測試再發布
K3全靠Fable的說法因此被削弱
回頭看，月之暗面早就被點名過
今年2月
Anthropic就指控月之暗面用假帳號跟Claude交換超過340萬次
不過最大宗其實是MiniMax，次數更多
被白宮威脅制裁之後
月之暗面也沒有退讓：
7月27日照原訂計畫
公開Kimi K3的完整權重
精確說是開放權重
檔案一旦被下載，就收不回來了
至於讓模型自己念的那招
8月10日另一組研究人員發論文證明
重播加密推理確實可能讓較弱模型解出內容
研究涵蓋OpenAI、Anthropic和Google
漏洞之外，事情還升到國安層級
9月8日，NSA、
FBI和CISA聯合點名月之暗面等中國公司
工業規模蒸餾美國前沿模型
隔天中國商務部反駁沒有根據
揚言將採取反制
吵到這個地步，OpenAI反而很晚才開口：
直到9月30日才首次公開7月事件細節
離全面阻斷約64天
OpenAI說已封住這條跨對話重播路徑
但其他部署仍要補強
細節公開了，事情卻還沒落槌
OpenAI沒公開IP、付款資料等歸因證據
月之暗面也還沒逐點回應到10月1日
美國制裁名單也沒新增月之暗面
這場爭議，還沒有定案